so we're here to talk about parsnip
there's the there's a heck sticker of
course it's the first thing we did so
you know I've talked about this and
you're probably sick of seeing this but
you know there's there's a bunch of
things so the unofficial like J didn't
say this but the unofficial job that I
have in our studio and others do is to
like these are my words like make our
suck laughs right so the things that we
don't like about our that sometimes are
frustrating like that's what a lot of
the tiny bursts does and since I mostly
work on modeling you know you can see
the the sort of like indictments here of
the parts of modeling in our that are a
little bit painful if you do it there's
things like you know some models have
like a formula method or a non foreigner
method packages you don't necessarily
know which one is wit or they're gonna
have which one they don't have there's
things like the one that's like the
fresh mate frustrating for me for a long
time is models you know when you build a
model and you go to make predictions and
they forget that the data frame you're
using has some missing values in it and
so let's say you have a hundred rows and
like two missing values and so most of
the predict methods you get like ninety
eight things back right and then they're
like oh yeah how do I put that back you
know how do I hadn't break this egg and
so you know there's just like various
things for like a long time that I've
been building up because that you know
before joining our studio I used to do
modeling for a living so so there's like
lists there of things that are just a
little bit frustrating and then you know
the the table on the side is more the
table I've been talking about with
carrot about you know there's the api's
with packages can be so different it
could be really frustrating having to
remember all that so you've probably
heard that before from me so you know I
wrote care about like in 2005 and and
characters like a variety of different
things but one of the things it does is
it works on solidifying like a like a
simple API that you can use and let the
art package figure out well what does
that mean for extra boost what does that
mean for LM and so on and so that works
pretty well but with the tiny models
packages we're developing we want to you
know we've gotten released
I've gotten I think better at api's I
never really thought about it and when
you work for somebody badly who you know
that's like his main thing is like let's
write better api's then you know
we think there's maybe a better way of
doing this and so so what parsnip is
it's only the part of carrot that's
designed there similar to the part of
carrot that's designed to like solidify
like a single API that you can work on
and not have to worry about what the
underlying model function or package
requires you to do so that's all that it
is so one thing we do differently in
parsnip is we organize around model type
right so if you're fitting like a linear
regression right it slopes and
intercepts that's a pretty common
structure for a model or if you're
fitting a decision tree so you know when
when we talk about you've seen a minute
when we setup a model you start off with
what kind of model do you want to use
and then after that you specify well
what's the computational engine and
that's kind of a mash up of the actual
implementation or the estimation method
right so like Stan might be a
computational engine which if you're
fitting like a linear regression model
it's not only a different package but
it's a whole different estimation
procedure and let's say LM or Clement
and things like that
so the idea is you specify the type of
model that you want and then you specify
like how slash where do i you know
estimate that width so that's like how
it generalizes things it has a tidy
interface so you can imagine there's
like a lot of pipes involved and then
the thing that like is we worked on the
most I think is having a predictable
object come back so whether you're
predicting or getting a model object you
always should know with parsing of what
you're getting and I'll talk about that
in a minute or two we spent a lot of
time and talking to people and
formulating things there's a link there
where we wrote like some guidelines for
what we think model should do like just
the like specifications but like things
like you know with predict always return
the same number of rows that you were
given right and that's so we're trying
to like going for we're trying to solve
the problem of you know people who don't
aren't software engineers who haven't
been using our for a while they might
have like an autumn awesome like
modeling method but they don't really
know anything about making our packages
especially once your models and so these
guidelines is where the packages we're
developing are set up so that you know
you just drop in your computational
algorithm that you're really really good
at and let us work out the whole
interface stuff because that's kind of
what we do so parsnip is the first step
and
that direction there's two blog posts
that are linked there one was when I
first launched it and the other I wrote
last week and then I I wrote it like a
few months ago and then finally I was
like oh right I need to you know make
this public and I forgot I had wrote in
a line that people tweeted about it's
like if you look at how parsnip works
quote you might question our sanity but
you know so that that second blog post
is really about like this is why because
I rewrote this in like four times like
why we did it the way we did it so if
you're a glutton for punishment go check
that out so just some code we have a
sort of a meta package called toddy
models that loads parsnip and our sample
and recipes and all that stuff and so
you can see where we create that first
regression model object all we're saying
is hey you know we're going to do linear
regression and there's some common
parameters that you might fit in various
linear regression model so if you were
doing some sort of regular eyes model
like glim net or Ridge regression or
laughs or something like that we sort of
abstract out the arguments to so you
know glim net might lose lambda and
another package might use this we try to
come up with a standardized set of non
jargony argument names so lambda doesn't
really tell you much unless you read the
papers involving this stuff so we use
words like penalty and so on
just to standardize that so you would
specify what model you want to use and
any arguments that you know about that
you want to fix and then at that point
you really haven't done anything there's
our data involved there so it's just
like a specification right and so once
you have the specification you can set
the engine and the engine again could be
you know whatever we have implemented
for that type of model but it's in this
case let's say glim net since we have
that penalty parameter there so you
never really have to use this translate
function that's on the right but just to
give you an idea what happens is and
again I haven't shown you any or haven't
shown the code any data yet but it does
a translation it says okay when we fit
the glim net model we're gonna have X is
going to be wrapped and so it's just
it's called missing R because we haven't
specimen a date specified any data there
but you can see for linear regression
fills in the family should be Gaussian
it translates penalty to lambda and so
on so again much like carrot it's doing
the whole translation to what Glenn met
once or Stan or LM or whatnot for you
and you don't have to really worry about
the details
so again like glim net it's a great
model but I'm frequently confounded by
that package and like one of those
simplest things that I could point out
is the interface of glim net is it
always requires a matrix for your
predictors not like a data frame it
doesn't take the formula method so you
know again like I've made this joke in
the workshop the other day like
sometimes I'm using extra boost or glut
net you know the question I'm I'm doing
different things for those packages and
and I ask myself like it's Gleb
networking for me or am i working for
glim dad right and so we want to catch
you all away from that so so for example
once you've set the engine in the model
type then you can run a fit function on
that so if you just use the fit you can
give it a formula and whether the
underlying model takes a formula or not
it just makes that all happen or you
could do fit underbar XY and give it X Y
even if it takes a formula so you don't
they're really worried about like how
does the data get there just give the
data that you think it should get in the
format that you want it in or the form
at least maybe you have it in and so on
so so that's sort of how it works in a
really simple way and you can see those
two model results are the same despite
how we specified the predictor similar
so Jarrod kind of stole my slide the
other day I mean I appreciate it but I
had a slide where I fit the like you
know empty cars like Stan and LM and so
what I did is just has a different
example you can set up a boosted tree in
this case would be a regression tree I'm
sorry a classification tree cuz its iris
and you know the arguments I used were
trees in men N and so those get
translated to the appropriate arguments
in XG boosts or in this case c5 right so
you know you it would be legit for you
to be like oh well yeah all these are
these packages have different arguments
now you give me like another set of
arguments to memorize and that's not
false but you know hopefully this would
be like the last set of arguments you'll
have to memorize for what those
functions do and you can see that
outputs kind of messy for what those
packages give you but like if you look
at on the left you can see that it
translates the argument for trees into
what actually boosts uses which is n
rounds and then yeah you can see it on
the right-hand side see 500 calls the
trials
so again you don't have to memorize any
of that stuff you just memorize the top
level sort of functions the other
notable thing about this is you might
notice if you use recipes or deep liar
you know we're we're very much
exploiting the idea of like delayed
execution right so most fitting
functions when you give them a formula
and things like that they automatically
instantly evaluate all the arguments and
so what we're doing a lot and the tiny
vs. we're saying well what can we buy
ourselves if we don't immediately
evaluate those things we store them as
expressions and their environments you
know can we redo things we couldn't have
normally done by not just immediately
eagerly executing and evaluating those
arguments that's a lot of what's going
on to the hood all right so predictions
like this was italicized and like bolded
it will always give you the same number
of things that you came in with you make
you start with one hundred rows and your
data frame you get a hundred predictions
back now you know it's a tidy verse
right so we're not going to give you a
vector back so you know we've
standardized and documented you're
always going to get the the right or the
same format back so if you're making
predictions on a regression model like a
univariate regression model you'll
always get a table back with a column
name called dot pred right so in case
you have a predictor in your data set
called pred like don't do that but like
you know just in case you go to see
Bonnie sings and together you're not to
worry about name conflicts so we like
dot everything which is not uncommon in
a lot of what we do you can see they're
like I take the first 30 data points and
then predict on the remaining three and
you see we get three rows back so let's
maybe induce a missing value and then
you can see that when you run the
predict method you get a missing value
back and the first one so you can still
see behind these things in together so
that for our our predict method for
parsnip there's no real na action dot
whatever like we just we give you what
you start off with which is good now
you if you've used glib net you might
realize that the prediction method is
actually more complex complex than that
so the way Klim networks is blue net
fits basically a series of penalty
parameters when it does this regular
honest regression and you don't actually
need to say what the penalty is until
you go to make predictions
so the cool thing about that is when
you're doing model tuning if you're
evaluating that model over many
different values of the penalty you
don't have to refit that model over and
over again you can fit one model and
then get predictions on all the sub
models you might want to evaluate and so
we wanted to facilitate that and parsnip
like we do in care in other places now
we went like back and forth about this
so much like how do we do that in the
predict method and we figured out that
like making the predict method work with
those particular types of models was
going to make it difficult for all the
other types of models that don't use
that feature so then the answer we came
up with is have something called multi
predict method which is saying that like
I'm gonna get multiple sub models back
okay so you would use when you want to
be in that mode you use a separate
prediction method on that same object to
get many different predictions from many
different models but you know I did say
that we will always give you a Tibble
back with the same number of rows that
you started out with so if I go to make
a prediction on 30 like empty cars and
have 32 data points I should get 32 rows
back but then I have multiple lambda
predictions across all bones and so what
we decided to do is very consistent with
deep hire and tidy our is we give you
like a nested list of tables inside that
so you can see I'm still making
predictions on three rows but I have 80
turns out for these data I have 80
possible lambda values that would make
predictions on this my teamwork might
seem your bike wow that's complicated
it's way less complicated than what Glen
net gives you and you'll just have to
take my word for that but if you were to
look at let's see the first element of
that well that's easy because they're
all in a because our first row of the
original data set we induce an n/a value
but what you can see in that top part on
the right is we have a value for the
actual argument that you're getting
prediction server penalty in this case
and then dot pred right so if you look
at the second element of that nested
table or that list column with tables in
it you can see that for different values
of the penalty I have the the dot pred
so I'm getting all those and you know
you can just use a simple tidy are
[Music]
unnecessary
but you're always against
with the end you came in with so one one
funny thing like funny story um we
figured out like in recipes and some of
this you know I'm really you might not
be surprised by this I'm really big in a
resampling right and so a lot of times
what we want to do is take the model
that we have and feeded different
variations of the original data to see
what the variability is and so when I
was thinking about this I was like wow
like we want people to specify the
arguments to the to the you know the
model object before they run in but we
don't necessarily know what those
arguments should be so just as an
example like random for says M try and M
try should be on the the units of the
original number of predictors in the
date I'm sorry yeah predictors in the
data set so it like if you have iris mm
try could be anywhere from 1 to 4 and
that's pretty easy right but what
happens when you're doing some fancy
pre-processing method or with dummy
variables and you you make dummy
variables out of your your factor
predictors you may not know what the the
number of columns you get are but you
need to specify em try so you don't at
the time where you have the data you
don't know what the size of the data
will be when it actually goes to fit
this model okay and since we delay
execution of everything you can't
necessarily do anything because if you
remember like when I did my fit
specification or my model specification
like linear reg there doesn't I mean how
would you parameterize that in terms of
number of columns instead of the actual
number so we thought about this a lot
and came up with a side table we call
data descriptors so at the time that the
app our stuff actually evaluates the the
data set it's using on the model like it
fits the model you have available to you
some sort of like like dummy functions
they work but they don't work outside of
any other context they capture different
characteristics of your data set so if
you want to know like how many how many
rows do I have let's say your parameter
or your tuning parameter depends on
number of rows like let's say some
number of nearest neighbors instead of
you putting in a solid number that may
or may not be consistent with let's see
the resampled version of that you can
use dot abs as a function if you are
going to convert if you have any
factored columns dot Preds is the number
of columns before in the data set before
you make any indicator
variables and then I had to look because
I don't use it that much like doc calls
is the number of predictors after you
make dummy variables so you can use
these things as if they were functions
when you specify your model so it just
as an example for random forests I could
say let's fit a random force it's the
unsub us a thousand trees and I want em
try to be 3/4 of my of my columns right
whatever that you know number of columns
ends up being and so basically what
happens is person if captures that as an
expression and then it only evaluates
that expression right at the time you go
to fit the model so whatever that
resolves to for that particular data set
is what you'll get back and so when you
see when you run that you can see at the
bottom
we haven't actually fit it yet when we
run the translate statement the M try
has that expression in it it has not
been evaluated yet which it couldn't be
because we don't it's not the time it's
going to be evaluated when we go to fit
let's say we use empty cars it turns out
you can see the math checks out at the
bottom the number of predictor of
predictors would be I don't know how
many it is like 11 for this data set but
it's number of columns minus 1 and then
75% of that is 7 and then you can see in
the random forest output it gets you 7
predictors okay so it's a way to
generalize what you're working on you
know knowing like a lot of the modeling
stuff we think we have all the
descriptors in there for the possible
things you might want to do so if you
like you want to down sample your data
if you have a big class imbalance there
rain of forests for example has a strata
parameter then you can say hey within
this variable sample this many at random
this many rows of the data that have
that value so if you stratify on your
outcome data you might say well let's
say you have a data set with 100 data
points and 90 of them or the majority
class and 10% or the minority you want
to have it randomly stratify stratify
the majority class down to the minority
within each tree that's what random
force would do but again if you don't
know whether it should be 10 or 9 or 13
or you know what what not you can give
it basically use those data descriptors
to detect that at the time it goes to do
predictions ok so it seems kind of
complicated but it's it's it's pretty
easy to do at least in the code if you
were to try to execute dot prayer
outside like just an open code it would
say yeah you know you can't do that okay
just like future plans like what we're
working on is the main thing I'm working
on right now is if you have like a
modeling package and you want to
basically make that work with parsnip
we're writing an API where you can sort
of like register your model with parsnip
and have it work like you can always
send ups like and people have like PR so
if you want to include something but
let's say you're working on your
dissertation and you'd like to use this
infrastructure but you don't want to
like you know publicize what your
dissertation topic is you know we're
working that API that will let you do
that
you know Kay sweets are implemented yet
so that's there's like placeholders but
it's not actually done yet
we also are coming up with like a
pipeline type package like if you're on
Twitter like you could see I've talked
about this a few times and a pipeline
would basically integrate like a recipe
a parsnip model and then maybe a post
processor that calibrates probabilities
from an earlier talk I there was a
question about like having monotonic
data so you in this workflow or this
pipeline you could add like a step in
there that says I need all my
probabilities to be monotonically
increasing so the workflow object would
take different things and would have its
own fit function so you don't have to
call a recipe and do a bunch of stuff
and then we call parsnip and do a bunch
of stuff well like bundle all these
actions together and then just the last
thing is you know if you think about
like can people have like well how about
adding Vista to parsnip or that it just
as an example like the simple
repeated-measures model with you know
just unordered replicates and you could
fit that using like a non Bayesian mix
model or hierarchical linear model or
generalized estimating equations so we
kind of want to take sometimes like
experimental designs and have those be
parsnip methods so you can fit various
types of models that kind of like
different estimators of the same
structural model but it doesn't have to
be like linear regression it might be
more geared towards the experimental
design so we definitely want to hear
from people saying like Oh have you
thought about this or how would you
structure that so please get in contact
with us and I think that is it
you